Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
After around 160 episodes into Two Minute
Papers, I think it is no secret to anyone
that I am helplessly addicted to fluid simulations,
so you can already guess what this episode
will be about.
I bet you will be as spellbound by this beautiful
footage of wet sand simulations as I was when
I've first seen it.
Before you ask, yes, I have attempted to prepare
some slow-motion action too!
As you remember, simulating the motion of
fluids involves solving equations that tell
us how the velocity and the pressure evolves
in time.
Now, the 3D world we live in is a continuum,
and we cannot solve these quantities everywhere
because that would take an infinite amount
of time.
To alleviate this, we can put a grid in our
virtual world and obtain these quantities
only in these gridpoints.
The higher the resolution the grid is, the
more realistic the animations are, but the
computation time also scales quite poorly.
It is really not a surprise that we have barely
seen any wet sand simulations in the visual
effects industry so far.
Here, we have an efficient algorithm to handle
these cases, and as you will see, this is
not only extremely expensive to compute, but
nasty stability issues also arise.
Have a look at this example here.
These are sand simulations with different
cohesion values.
Cohesion means the strength of intermolecular
forces that hold the material together.
The higher cohesion is, the harder it is to
break the sand up, the bigger the clumps are.
This is an important quantity for our simulation
because the higher the water saturation of
this block of sand, the more cohesive it is.
Now, if we try to simulate this effect with
traditional techniques on a coarse grid, we'll
encounter a weird phenomenon: namely, the
longer our simulation runs, the larger the
volume of the sand becomes.
An excellent way to demonstrate this phenomenon
is using these hourglasses, where you can
clearly see that after only a good couple
turns, the amount of sand within is significantly
increased.
This is particularly interesting, because
normally, in classical fluid simulations,
if our grid resolution is insufficient, we
typically encounter water volume dissipation,
which means that the total amount of mass
in the simulation decreases over time.
Here, we have the exact opposite, like in
a magic trick, after every turn, the volume
gets inflated.
That's a really peculiar and no less challenging
problem.
This issue can be alleviated by using a finer
grid, which is, as we know, extremely costly
to compute, or, the authors proposed a volume
fixing method to take care of this without
significantly increasing the execution time
of the algorithm.
Make sure to have a look at the paper, which
is certainly my kind of paper: lots of beautiful
physics and a study on how to solve these
equations so that we can obtain an efficient
wet sand simulator.
And also, don't forget, a fluid paper a day
keeps the obsessions away.
In the meantime, a word about the Two Minute
Papers shirts.
I am always delighted to see you Fellow Scholars
sending over photos of yourselves proudly
posing with your newly obtained shirts for
the series.
Thanks so much and please, keep them coming!
They are available through twominutepapers.com
for the US, and the EU and worldwide link
is also available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!